>>> SO INTERNAL DIVISION,
ARGUING AMONGST THEMSELVES,
COMPLAINING TO FRIENDS AND
FAMILY BACK HOME ABOUT MOSCOW'S
DECISION MAKING.
THAT'S HOW SOME OFFICERS IN THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY ARE DEALING
WITH UKRAINIE'S COUNTER
OFFENSIVE.
I WANT TO BRING IN RETIRED MAJOR
MARK LIONS.
JUST REMIND US WHERE THE RUSSIAN
TROOPS ARE IN UKRAINE.
WHERE ARE MOST OF THEM?
>> BECAUSE OF THE UKRAINIAN
OFFENSIVE, THEY MADE THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR TROOPS DOWN
HERE IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF THE
COUNTRY AND MOST OF THE UKRAINE
OFFENSIVE CAME UP FROM THE
NORTH.
THIS IS THE UKRAINE OFFENSIVE
HERE.
WHAT HAPPENED HERE, THE BETTER
TROOPS ARE NOW ALIGNED IN THE
SOUTH HOLDING OFF WHAT THEY
THOUGHT WAS GOING TO BE THE MAIN
OFFENSIVE HERE.
THE RIVER HAS BECOME A HUGE
ADVANTAGE BECAUSE THEY DROPPED
THE BRIDGES ALONG THE RIVER.
THE REASON WHY RUSSIAN GENERALS
ARE CONCERNED, THEY RECOGNIZE
THERE'S 20 TO 30,000 TROOPS IN
THIS REGION AT GREAT RISK,
POTENTIALLY COULD SURRENDER.
THEY COULD BE SURROUNDED AND THE
RUSSIAN GENERALS KNOW WE HAVE TO
GET TROOPS TO REINFORCE THIS
QUICKLY.
>> THEY'RE FIGHTING HERE,
FIGHTING HERE.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT 300,000
REINFORCEMENTS, PUTIN IS ASKING
FOR 300,000 WHERE WOULD THEY GO?
>> THEY HAVE TO GET TO THIS SPOT
HERE BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE THAT
CRIMEA IS LIKELY THE ALAMO FOR
RUSSIA.
THEY CANNOT LOSE THIS AREA HERE,
THEY CANNOT LOSE THIS LAND
BRIDGE.
THEY HAVE THE NAVAL BASE THERE,
THAT'S THE ONLY WARM WATER PORT.
300,000 THIS IS NOT
INSEQUENTIAL.
THIS IS A HUGE AMOUNT OF MEN
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THEM TO THE
LINES THERE.
THE QUESTION IS HOW FAST CAN
THEY GET THERE?
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO CARE IF
THEY'RE TRAINED OR NOT.
THEY'LL JUST THROW THEM IN.
>> WHEN WE HEAR THE REPORTING,
BEYOND LOW MORALE, DISSENSION
WITHIN THE RANKS, LACK OF
COMMUNICATION, HOW DOES THAT
IMPACT THE TROOPS THERE?
>> I THINK THE WAY UKRAINE GETS
INITIATIVE BACK SAY A MAJOR UNIT
SURRENDERS YOU COULD HAVE 20 TO
30,000 TROOPS SURRENDER KNOWING
THEY'RE GOING TO BE CUT OFF
THERE.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS SURRENDER THEY
SURRENDER THE EQUIPMENT AND THAT
GETS TURNED BACK AROUND AND USED
AGAINST RUSSIA.
>> THIS EMOTIONAL AND MORALE
BATTLE WITHIN RUSSIA AND THE
TROOPS THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ALSO HAVE SALMA ABDELAZIZ STANDING BY
WE HAVE BEEN SEEING THE
RETALIATION ON THE ANNOUNCEMENT
OF THIS PARTIAL MOBILIZATION
OUT OF RUSSIA.
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE FORM OF
PEOPLE TRYING TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN AGGRESSION ON
THE GROUND AS WELL.
AT LEAST IT IS NOT HITTING HOME
FOR MANY RUSSIANS.
THIS IS NOT JUST A SPECIAL
MILITARY OPERATION, THIS
ACTUALLY COULD MEAN WAR.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT ALL COMES ON THE BACK OF
THESE MAJOR LOSSES ON THE
GROUND FOR RUSSIAN TROOPS.
UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE ABLE TO
CLAW BACK THOUSANDS OF MILES OF
TERRITORY.
THIS WEEK, PRESIDENT PUTIN
ISSUED HIS RESPONSE INTO PARTS.
FIRST, ON A REFERENDUM THAT
SO-CALLED REFERENDUM IF YOU
WILL.
BEN WEDEMAN WAS SPEAKING ABOUT
IT.
THE OTHER PART OF PUTIN'S
APPROACH IS HAPPENING VERY MUCH
INSIDE RUSSIA.
THAT IS THE CALL FOR HIS
PARTIAL MOBILIZATION.
300,000 RESERVISTS NOW WILL BE
DEPLOYED TO UKRAINE, IS GONNA
HAPPEN IN STAGES ACCORDING TO
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS.
PEOPLE ARE PANICKING, QUITE
LITERALLY THERE WERE
DEMONSTRATIONS IN 30 CITIES
ACROSS RUSSIA.
A BRUTAL CRACKDOWN.
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE ARRESTED,
MANY OF THOSE DETAINED, WOMEN
WHO DID NOT WANT TO SEE THEIR
BROTHERS, THEIR SONS, THEIR
FATHERS SENT OFF TO THAT WAR
QUITE LITERALLY TO DIE.
IT IS ALSO TRIGGERED A EXODUS
IF YOU WILL BUY LAND AND AIR.
INFORMATION IS SHOWING THAT
FLIGHT TICKETS OUT OF RUSSIA TO
A NEARBY CITY COST OVER 5000
DOLLARS PER TICKET, IT WOULD
NORMALLY COST ONLY A FEW
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
STILL, PEOPLE ARE PANIC BUYING,
JUST BOOKING ANYTHING THEY CAN
TO GET OUT OF THE COUNTRY BY
LAND.
I KNOW YOU HAVE THOSE PICTURES
TO SHOW.
THERE ARE HUGE CUES, VERY LONG
LINES OF TRAFFIC, OF CARS
WAITING FOR HOURS TO TRY TO GET
OUT.
FINLAND, THE BORDER WITH
FINLAND, ONE OF THE FEW
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES THAT STILL
HAS ITS LAND BORDER OPEN TO
RUSSIA.
THERE IT IS, OFFICIALS SPEAKING
OF A SURGE OF PEOPLE TRYING TO
FLEE THE COUNTRY.
KAZAKH STANN OF COURSE AS WELL,
BOARDING WITH RUSSIA, SAYING
THERE IS A 20% INCREASE IN
TRAFFIC ALONG THAT BORDER.
FAMILIES IN RUSSIA ARE NOT JUST
AFRAID ABOUT THIS MOBILIZATION.
THERE IS A FEAR THAT THIS IS
GOING.
IT IS EXPANDING.
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T HAVE A
HOLD OF IT.